well that's what I when I was training
for that MMA fight against the comedian
I trained with Bisping twice and I
grapple with this being a piss pants not
even known for his jujitsu of course he
is he's got very much ramped up I know
his guard his defensive guards one of
the best in MMA
very rarely do people pass his guard
when he's on the ground he's excellent
but primarily you know he's known as a
striker yeah I merrily primarily duh I
can't explain to you it was like I felt
like a lion was just toying with me it
it was and it was it was a strange thing
because I'd never in my life cuz you
obviously you know an MMA fighter can
beat you up you know a professional
mixed martial artists can beat you up
but I don't think people realize how
badly and how big of the gap it is
because it's not it's but they don't
know Joe you know people have no fucking
clue until you do it I had no idea until
this is last summer and I judge and he
was fucking around with me for a second
you know it was terrifying and I feel
like less of a man I can't look at my
son in the eyes it's the same way that I
used to be able to I don't fuck right
you know what it's like oh come on
you'll be all right you know what it's
like it's like do you know how people
see someone do stand-up and they think I
could fuck could do that everyone that's
how we all started right but because
you're just talking you guys just
talking yeah that's what fighting it's
like it's like you look at a guy like
Bisping and you know he's like a normal
guy he's obviously very athletic and
he's big and everything like that but
he's he's not Shaquille O'Neal he's like
some 7-foot Samson specimen
he's regular-sized human see like well
he's moving like a regular human I could
do that but you have no idea no you're
beyond helpless you have no idea
literally yeah you have no idea you
grabbed a hold of you you're you're a
dead person almost anybody in the UFC
any person the average person even if
you're training it doesn't matter they
can take you just let them do what they
want to do yeah there's the intellectual
levels like I always feel like whenever
I talk to people that are really smart
they're gonna have a Sean Carroll or a
neil degrasse tyson or someone on the
podcast you talked to me just like
goddamn I'm fucking stupid yeah you know
there's just just levels to this just
levels to this understanding of life
that's like but that's with everything
with stand-up with artwork with with
someone choking the life out of you
got this day man I've been doing jujitsu
since 1996 if I roll with certain people
just it's a matter when I'm gonna get
strangled yeah
they don't even have to be bigger than
me be smaller than means when am I gonna
tap when's it coming I had a friend of
mine now who's like a really athletic
dude who I got he does that every
difference a friend of a friend but he
trains out of uh he's like a trainer out
of a Gracie School in Florida there's
only one time he he got to roll with
hoist Gracie and I said nah I was like I
was what was it like was it like was he
like that much better I think this guy's
a high level black belt like he's like
dude he was like we talk about levels he
was like he was toying with me like I
had never done it before and that's how
I that's how good those guys are